when a hyper-aggressive lizard or an
evil living cowheart starts rampaging
through your town or a sinister salesman
turns up in your home who you gonna call
hint it's not the ghostbusters the
answer is the scp foundation's mobile
task force you probably heard them
mentioned in every single video on this
channel but what exactly is a mobile
task force what do they do for the scp
foundation and what are some of the most
famous mobile task forces in the field
let's crack open the files and take a
look in short mobile task forces are the
foundation's elite personnel and each
task force is generally made up of
highly trained foundation operatives
with specific skill sets these mts
aren't rooted in any one base and are
relocated to wherever they're required
hence the mobile part of the name the
exact parameters on what an mtf can be
is pretty flexible the size of their
units can vary from whole battalions of
troops packing heavy artillery to small
tight-knit groups of
intelligence-gathering spies some mobile
task forces are bound to specific scps
whereas others perform more generalized
tasks such as securing certain
facilities or territories when the
regular rank and file foundation field
agents can't do the job the mtfs are
brought in to pick up the pieces each
group is controlled by a mobile task
force commander who reports to the
foundation director of task forces
though the actual organizational
structure of each group varies sometimes
mtfs which were created for extremely
specific purposes are disbanded after
that purpose is achieved how many mobile
task forces are there exactly the exact
number is shrouded in secrecy and often
times the answer will depend on who you
ask but you're not here for what we
don't know you want to know the details
on the biggest badasses under the
foundation's employ and we intend to
deliver much like our video on the
proposals for scp-001
we're going to give you a rapid fire
crash course on some of the most
prominent and interesting foundation
task forces and remember if you want us
to go more in depth into the most
exciting missions of any of these groups
let us know in the comments but for now
it's time for a rundown of the
foundation's best of the best mtf alpha
1 aka red right hand are essentially the
black ops of the scp foundation they
report directly to the o5 council and
conduct missions at the highest level of
secrecy with most of the information
hidden behind a level 5 clearance wall
many also believe alpha 1 to have links
to the infamous chaos insurgency a
splinter group at war with the
foundation but if anyone asks you didn't
hear it from us seriously we don't want
to get assassinated ntf alpha 4 aka pony
express are a covert group deeply
embedded into the world's logistics and
postal services the trafficking of
anomalous objects is a worldwide issue
and it's up to alpha 4 to intercept and
keep a lid on those anomalous objects
before they fall into the wrong hands
think of them as a better funded
paranormal usps police division one
object they've prevented from reaching
the public is scp-3060
a series of cpap machines that cause
nighttime visions of frightening
entities mtf omega-7 aka pandora's box
was an experimental task force which
incorporated the use of highly combat
effective scps including
scp-076 better known as able the tests
showed initial success but after they
ran out of missions abel's blood lust
proved to be too great for the team to
control and the experiment as well as
the task force were scrapped however
this led to the creation of mtf alpha 9
aka last hope this is a mobile task
force designed to train viable scps to
provide services to the foundation out
in the field this group has learned the
lessons of its predecessor and has
employed the use of more measured and
reasonable anomalies those include
scp-073 or kane the much more
even-tempered brother of able mtf beta 7
aka the mass hatters are the elite
cleanup crew for anomalous biohazards
chemical spills and radiological
disasters so if an area suddenly looks
like it's going to become chernobyl's
scarier sequel or an anomalous fast
spreading disease is wrecking havoc over
a wide area the mass hatters are the
guys to call they worked closely on the
containment of scp-1280 a kind of
parasitic nematode worm that often
injects false memories into their
victims mtf gamma 5 aka red herrings are
the foundation's chief disinformation
division they prevent the leaks of
classified info to the public and on the
rare occasions that this information
does somehow get out they're in charge
of burying it and administering
necessary amnestic treatments to those
affected it's a thankless job but you
won't remember they did it either way
they gave amnesic treatment to the
traumatized victims of scp-1618
a malevolent urinal which replaced the
user's valuables with disgusting
alternatives from toilet paper to pig
intestines ntf gamma 6 aka deep feeders
investigate and track deep sea or
oceanic anomalies a job that commands
the ultimate respect from people with
philosophia that's the fear of the deep
ocean if something terrifying and
mysterious is stirring down there in the
abyss you better believe gamma 6 are
going to be the first ones down they
keep a close eye on a number of
anomalies such as scp-1264
an underwater amalgamation of sunken
ships eager to drag down more vessels
and add them to its mass mtf gamma 13
aka asimov's lawbringers are a
specialized task force devoted to
investigating tracking and apprehending
anomalies originating from anderson
robotics a group of interests that
produces anomalous robots and machines
this includes examples of scp-2806 a
number of advanced anomalous prosthetic
body parts that wish to attach
themselves to a lacking host whether
they want it or not mtf delta 5 aka
front runners are a large group of
autonomous deep cover agents buried in
various groups of interest across the
globe it's their job to gather
intelligence from within to aid in the
apprehension of anomalies before these
groups can get their hands on them they
also sometimes make use of anomalies to
track down others such as when they
requested to use scp-185
a russian r105m radio used during the
cold war that can receive signals from
any time period including encrypted ones
but can also emit sound waves so
powerful they can literally kill you mtf
epsilon 9 aka fire eaters are the
foundation's resident pyromaniacs
they're the ones sent into missions
involving extremely high temperature
environments and they're also highly
skilled in the use of powerful
incendiary weapons if the foundation
needs to burn or avoid getting burned
the fire eaters are the ones for the job
their vital skills assisted in
containing scp-165
massive colonies of carnivorous
parasitic mites that eat prey to the
bone mtf epsilon 11 nine-tailed fox are
another one of the most classified
mobile task forces existing only under
the oversight of the red right hand they
work internally and are only dispatched
to foundation sites when standard
protocols fail and multiple breaches are
imminent they were brought in to deal
with the
scp-2139 incident a strange
psychological phenomenon that
inexplicably increased the
suggestibility of foundation staff at
site-35 this made the infected staff
agree with everything they heard mtf
zeta-9 mole rats are a task force that
specializes in the exploration and
containment of anomalous areas that are
either enclosed or underground
particularly if due to the effects of
the anomaly the space-time fabric of the
area is unstable you may remember them
from our series on scp-1730 the mission
into and out of the anomalous site 13.
mtf 8-10 aka see no evil are a team that
specializes in taking on dangerous memes
and cognito hazards that affect the
victims through visual contact one
example is
scp-1561 a crown that when worn causes
all those who see the person wearing the
crown to imagine the wearer as their
king and immediately adopt positions of
servitude while mtf eta 10 aka savage
beasts serve the opposite purpose they
deal with musical or auditory anomalies
and any cognitohazards that work through
the medium of sound like
scp-2402 a chord progression which can
regenerate all their dying cells mtf
theta 4 aka gardeners are a crack team
of agents who face off against any
botanical or plant-like anomalies their
skills were put to use against scp-1147
a collection of plum tree seeds which
can grow out of literally any substance
even ones that are totally inorganic mtf
theta 90 aka angle grinders are a team
that specialize in two of the most
frightening things out there anomalies
and math these brainiacs deal with
anomalous mathematical issues like
warped topologies and geometries even
listing an example of the kind of
anomalies they deal with here will make
your head hurt so just be thankful
they're out there ntf iota 10 or damn
feds are a huge network of undercover
agents based in federal and local law
enforcement agencies across the globe
they intercept any anomalous objects
beings or information and make sure that
it makes its way out of police evidence
lockers and into foundation hands
without incident mtf kappa 10 or skynet
is a temporary team of combined meet
space and virtual agents tracking down
and disrupting anomalous cyber threats
such as
scp-2987 an external hard drive
basically capable of turning artificial
intelligences into living souls for
trades with soul-consuming anomalies mtf
lambda 5 aka white rabbits are a group
that specializes in combating reality
warpers of all types whether they're
messing with space-time or exhibiting
god-like powers some anomalies even
respond directly to them like scp-2446
a phenomenon where corpses often
identical to living white rabbits team
members suddenly manifest around san
jose california ntf lambda 12 pest
control are a group of agents who
exclusively go after anomalous vermin
incidentally they're one of the only
mtfs who've never lost members in the
line of duty their purview includes
scp-2810 an anomalous pathogen that
causes the victim cells to become tiny
versions of their own species like a
human cells becoming cell-sized humans
mtf limeda 14 one-star reviewers are a
task force that deal with
retail-oriented anomalies their main
focus has become combating a sinister
group of interest known as the ambrose
restaurant a chain of extra-dimensional
restaurants with strange and anomalous
food and service mtf mu 3 aka highest
bidders is a mobile task force devoted
to preventing the group of interest
marshall carter and dark limited from
disseminating dangerous anomalous
objects and then obtaining and
containing these objects one such object
is scp-2818 a number of 50-cal sniper
rifles that when fired turns the shooter
into a bullet and fires them ntf move 4
aka debuggers are particularly useful in
the modern age as they track and contain
anomalous electronics and technology
including isolating and containing
anomalous websites and software one of
the anomalies dealt with by the
debuggers is scp-896
an online role-playing game that
improves the physical and mental
attributes of the player when they name
their character after themselves
remember when we said you didn't need to
call the ghostbusters well that wasn't
entirely true sometimes you need to get
mtf mu 13 aka ghostbusters on the line
since they're an mtf whose specialty is
tracking intangible or incorporeal
anomalies particularly those considered
sapient or sentient and they're on call
24 hours a day to serve all your
supernatural containment needs like when
you're plagued by scp-1036 which are a
number of haunted congolese fetish dolls
mtf new 7 aka hammer down are the ones
you need to call when you need real
heavy duty work they're a huge force
with a massive stock of army vehicles
and heavy weaponry and are only called
in for truly catastrophic events they're
also assisted in the containment of
scp-939 the voice imitating amnestic
producing red monsters mtf epsilon 6 aka
village idiots are a group of agents
whose specialty is investigating and
containing anomalous phenomena that
occur in rural or suburban areas if you
live in a small town and you're on the
run from a vicious monster you better
hope the village idiots are on their way
they've contained scp-2561
a cat with a vintage television set for
a head capable of causing painful
tinnitus mtf pi one aka city slickers
are pretty much the exact opposite of
the village idiots they pursue anomalies
in densely populated urban areas
particularly in the new york
metropolitan area they assisted in the
ongoing containment of scp-1155
the incredibly bloodthirsty predatory
street art ntf sigma 66 aka 16 tons are
basically the foundation's own version
of the suicide squad they're a team made
from captured members of other groups of
interest who aren't particularly loyal
to the foundation but whose very
particular set of skills make up for
that fact mtf tau5 aka samsara are
another group you might remember from
the events of scp-1730
these are a group unlike any other
immortal cyborgs made from the flesh of
a dead god who can be upgraded as needed
they're equipped with experimental and
state of the art foundation technology
to take on thelmaturgic magical and
psionic threats mtf sci-7 aka home
improvement is a team specializing in
structural anomalies in plain speak they
deal with anomalous activities
concerning buildings containing and
sometimes even demolishing when
necessary with a variety of heavy
artillery for example they counteract
the nightmarish scp-35 a building in
north carolina that once a year fuses
all living matter inside its own
structure on an atomic level mtf psi 8
aka the silencers are a team devoted to
containing re-animation anomalies and
those who've been affected by them if
you've just come back from the dead then
the silencers are going to want to know
your location mtf omega 0 aka aura orun
are another highly classified mobile
task force that's actually the memories
of deceased foundation personnel
preserved on the foundation intranet
system their job is to protect their
surviving co-workers against
informational threats on the servers
they also contain
scp-3664 a damaged but highly advanced
assault rifle existing in the
non-physical conceptual space it can
only be interacted with by thinking
about interacting with it and last but
not least mtf omega 12 aka achilles heel
is an anomalous task force and these
powerful reality warpers from another
dimension hunt down dangerous and
powerful reality warpers in ours you can
thank these guys for every single day
that our reality continues on as normal
or whatever normal means now they're
enemies of scp-3155
members of the iconic pinkerton
detective agency with anomalous
abilities relating to combat all right
we did it of course even this is only a
sample of the vast number of mobile task
forces at the foundation's disposal who
put their lives at risk every day to
keep humanity normality and reality
intact they seem to have a task force
perfectly tailored to every threat we
could possibly encounter and as new
threats are cataloged more mobile task
forces are sure to arise to meet them
want more in-depth explorations of any
of these groups and their epic missions
let us know in the comments below now go
check out scp-1730 epic battle at site
13 and
scp-2662 ctulu for more of the mobile
task forces you love right now